[موسيقى]
العلم السعودي ويمكن من البدايات الاولى
للاسره من ابراهيم موسى بن ربيعه ما لم
يذكر ولا بينسب لال سعود ان وضع في يوم من
الايام الهلال لا في بدايه الاولى ولا في
الدوله السعوديه الاولى ولا الثانيه ولا
بدايه الملك عبد العزيز الملك عبد العزيز
يقول الريحاني حينما دخل الملك عبد العزيز
الى الرياض ذكر في تاريخه حينما دخل الملك
عبد العزيز للرياض كانت الرايه المحموله
معه
خضراء اللون جزء ابيض منها يلي الساريه
كتبت عليها اقرب الى هذا الشكل نعم لا اله
الا الله محمد رسول الله ويعلوف وسيفان
متقاطعان فلم يذكر ابدا هلال
[موسيقى]
او شيع من سنوات تقريبا ان من قام بتصميم
العلم هو مستشار الملك عبد العزيز الشيخ
حافظ وهبه المعلومه هذه غير موجوده ابدا
هناك تكليف من المغفور لها الملك المؤسس
الملك عبد العزيز طيب الله ثراه في عام
1937 حينما كلف
الهيئه الاستشاريه او قبل هذا التاريخ في
عام 26 26 ميلادي
1926,344 يعني من مئه سنه تقريبا كلف
الهيئه الاستشاريه في مناسبه البيعه ان
يقوموا والمكون من عدد المستشاري
والمندوبين ان يقوموا بعمل وتصميم شكل
العلم والعمله السعوديه ولكن اذا ظهرت على
شكل الحالي ولكن
حقيقه امر انه الشيخ حافظ وهبه هو من صمم
هذا العلم اعتقد لا يوجد لها مصدر
[موسيقى]